there are two amazing developments in
the 2020 Democratic primary from the
last 36 hours other than the fact that
New Hampshire voted and that Bernie
Sanders won the popular vote they're
tying Pete Budaj edge in terms of
Delegates revelation number one Bernie
Sanders has all of a sudden taken over
the lead not just in one national poll
but in the Real Clear Politics average
of recent polls that's number one we're
gonna look at some specific ones
number two we now have Michael Bloomberg
polling third nationally at 15 and 16
and even in a very recent poll 17% these
are stunning numbers for Michael
Bloomberg we don't yet know how his
numbers will be affected by the horribly
racist audio uncovered by our friend
Benjamin Dixon over the last 48 hours so
let's now look at the latest polls
Bernie Sanders in first place in the
latest Monmouth poll the latest
Quinnipiac poll and the latest morning
consult poll all highlighted in red on
the screen this is a major reversal
that's been building up over the last
six weeks now surpassing Joe Biden more
on that in a second and then incredibly
I mean really incredibly Michael
Bloomberg recently exposed talking very
racist ly about stop and frisk in audio
that was released by our good friend
Benjamin Dixon Bloomberg polling in 16%
in third place in the hill poll 15% in
third place in the queen of Quinnipiac
poll and there's another poll that just
came out an hour ago which we don't yet
have in front of us where Bloomberg is
polling 17% so this now shifts the
national race quite a bit the latest
national averages put Bernie Sanders
almost three full points ahead of Joe
Biden in the national averages Michael
Bloomberg has now surpassed not just
Pete Budaj edge but also Elizabeth
Warren in the national averages at
thirteen point six two Elizabeth
Warren's 13 so I told you weeks ago
without passing value judgment of
Bloomberg remember I'm not a Bloomberg
although I find his ads triggering
Donald Trump very funny I believe that
in the end Bloomberg is going to end up
third or maybe fourth in delegates
I think Biden is increasingly out I
believe Warren is increasingly out
Bloomberg is now third nationally
Warren's downfall continues Pete
continues to be solid we are going to
have several contenders here for some
time now as far as Michael Bloomberg
goes the question is 15% nationally is
great sixteen percent nationally is
great seventeen percent nationally is
great
he needs delegates where does he start
getting delegates because thirteen point
six percent nationally average is lovely
but there's a 15% viability threshold in
most of the primaries so where is
Michael Bloomberg in Nevada we have no
clue the latest poll is very old
where is Michael Bloomberg in South
Carolina nowhere ten days ago he was
polling one in South Carolina that's
okay in the sense that he's betting on
Super Tuesday so let's now look at some
Super Tuesday States in California
Bloomberg is polling four not enough to
get any delegates but where it gets
interesting for Bloomberg is that in
Texas he's polling 16 that would get him
a bunch of Delegates in Massachusetts
there's no polling since October we're
not sure in Florida to pick another
state Bloomberg is polling or was
polling 17 at the end of January Florida
and Texas are big states 219 delegates
in Florida 228 in Texas so just if
Bloomberg can eke out his 16% in Texas
and his 17% in Florida that's 73
delegates
that's way more than anyone has right
now of course other candidates will pick
up delegates in those states as well so
understand that this is a long game
I maintain Bloomberg will be a bigger
player than lots of people thought we
heard anecdotally during our New
Hampshire live stream yesterday that
some some callers whose friends or
family support Bloomberg were shown the
Ben Dixon audio the subtitled racist
audio of Michael Bloomberg
and every single one of them didn't care
so in the next week or so we will see
whether the Bendix and audio release
hurts Michael Bloomberg
I predict that if it does it will not be
significant that's just it's not my
opinion of the audio the audio is
horrible it's my prediction of how
voters will react so I want to hear from
you what do you think is happening with
Michael Bloomberg will the establishment
Democratic Party Democratic support
shift to Michael Bloomberg if Biden
continues to fall and warren continues
to fall in concert with Budaj edge and
amy klobuchar sort of being bumped up
and picking up delegates where do you
see Bloomberg's role here I know a lot
of people in the audience don't like him
particularly after that disgusting audio
I'm with you my friends this is an
analysis of what is not what we would
like and I believe Bloomberg is going to
be a significantly bigger player than a
lot of people in my audience and around
the country are giving him credit for
let me know and make sure to give us a
like on Facebook at facebook.com slash
David Pakman show after the break not
very much Trump content on today's show
for those of you who don't like Trump
content almost none of it today so far
we will talk about Donald Trump getting
his friend Roger stone who he barely
knows a lighter prison sentence and we
will also do an analysis of progressive
regressive and proportional taxes coming
up after this short break the vast
majority of news in the u.s. is
controlled by five huge corporations and
news voice is fighting back against
media monopolies it's the first-ever
entirely open crowd-sourced democratized
platform for news use the link right
underneath this video to download the
news voice app for free